picasso isidoro the service of a dog our
academic nipa Okajima Davina the sixties
and seventies was the where the national
feelings of grenadiers and their pride
of being in occur in Greenland was
becoming in and without that youthful
strength and inspiration during that
time I don't think that we could sit
here and talk happily about granitic
literature I think of a dog or deso casa
da da we don't have any chance for our
languages to survive if we don't use it
ourselves and it should start from the
birth until you die you have to have a
strong element of infrastructure in your
country where your language and your
culture is placed and it has to be not
only spoken in the year in the
legislature it has to be used in in
every media it has to be used in
business so in education becoming a day
or Europeanized or I'm a recognized
haven't helped any any person at all in
our areas you have to respect us with
the nation no background we have not
only ethnic we are a nation that are
placed in our country said that we have
colonized and you have to understand
that colonization will always destroy
the people that are colonized you cannot
change anything without fading
colonialism colonialism is also inside
you in your soul if you don't find it so
well so there's no one else in united
nations on whoever that can save your
your your language from dying it's
yourself or consuming it bad I let the
matter than that it's a mean and inhuman
policy not to respect languages that are
spoken by the people themselves if you
are going to educate people and you are
not using their languages it doesn't
help at all so that's why Greenland for
the last 30 years have been very
successful in using our own language in
integration from birth to death and it
is important to understand that
situation second if the Inuit are not
working together to have a solution on
the writing system then either of our
necklaces will survive so it is
important that we have a common
autocracy and that cooperation through
the Martin technologies are being used
so writing in West Green antic could be
easily understood in East Greenlandic or
it could be translated right away into a
new PR Alaska language or energy to
so the cadet it into it really need to
discuss with us very closely how we do
that and why it should start from the
scratch mainly to cheats to have a good
Inuit speaking teachers in the school
and start not tomorrow but today and
otherwise our like it will disappear as
I need not the new saw this II don't
need to shower it's not a question what
kind of feelings you have for one
language or the other but for your own
identity it is important to to respect
and understand your own identity first
that's a very important in a colonialist
education system like we have in most
northern North American institutions
it's like that greenland have been able
to change that turn it around because of
the we are using our rights for
self-determination it is important to
understand that the political decisions
can only be made if you have the right
to
precisely the language itself it's also
important to understand that the soul of
into it is very strong and we are all in
all only 150,000 people how can hundred
fifty thousand people have survived so
long it's such a harsh climatic
conditions because of our soul because
we have that here coming out of our
mouth when we are speaking in our own in
wit language and the artistic
expressions coming out of it are a
bountiful and people the rest of the
world needs to be to know a little more
about any culture other than the the
very narrow-minded descriptions if you
can call it of Yui it's not strange a
strange situation at all that people can
survive in the harshest to the climate
conditions of all that's not strange
that's that's not strange the strange
thing is how can the white people
survive in our area because we help them
without our help you cannot survive in
this harsh conditions so please don't
tell us what we can but we can tell you
what we can how we did that and that
will tell the rest of the world and oh
so many bad I said need no delena if we
should do something that creates a new
sense of togetherness among anyway then
I think
we should work closer together in
education in language policies and also
in in in enabling our artistic side of
our humanity to have a much more room
that it does today and that way we can
survive a lot of crisis in my opinion I
think it only takes a person up the
decision to do what we is needed for the
creation of a writing system that is
common and we can all read it then I'm
sure that the next edition of this book
would be much more interesting and we
will be able to be proud and say well
this is born out of resilience out of
our idea that even small people like us
small nations like us can surely play
games with the big nations as well and
that's that's the only reason we are
here that we don't want to pay with our
culture in order to to follow the
majority people which is of what kind of
people we should be it's it should be
our own decision what kind of persons we
are because no one can take away our
identity even you can color your hair
and put up false things in your face but
it doesn't change what is in here is the
Inuit soul and that's at the driving
force
without their base Latin assassin
notices are Tessa harmony e tutto
Colorado playback issue should know
Elena